Oh anybody here do you know what's going
on nobody else is awake
we woke up behind the years too soon
nice cameo we should go back to sleep
who wants to sleep on a beautiful day
like this there's something else going
on here
the greatest migration in human history
stranded on a sinking ship the controls
the engines it's all designed to keep us
out there has to be a way
this wasn't an axe
there's something they didn't tell us
here we go
there's a reason we woke up early rated
pg-13
in 3d and will be 3d
morning gravity failure
you
hello he asking me on a date
she didn't seem that impressed you clean
up pretty good herself
you two look fine this evening we're on
a date
very nice took you long enough to ask
so why did you give up your life on
earth
we boarded the Avalon with the
destination 120 years hibernation means
the wake up in a new century on a new
planet
a year ago everything changed
anybody there
do you know what's going on but nobody
else is awake I think something went
wrong with the hibernation box
you woke up too soon 9 years too soon
this came here we should go back to
sleep
we can't
something's wrong something big
what do we do now
do you trust me
the ship's gonna go
there's something I have to tell you
there's a reason we woke up early
you